sept milliards de personnes ont péri
lors de la dernière guerre
une somme les survivants
nous avons le choix entre créer un
nouveau futur ou remonter le temps et
tout recommencer on se retrouve dans le
traité
parfois j'aimerais que le voyage dans le
temps n'ait jamais existé
la cavale c'est que nous sommes capables
de changer le futur de les faire
disparaître de l'histoire et c'est
précisément ce que nous allons faire
je l'utilisé les rebelles
si on part tout de suite en aura
peut-être une chance aux joueurs de
faire quoi le temps on voudrait regarder
l'histoire se répéter
capable un nouveau chasseur qui agit
dans cet espace temps
en dessous plus à ce jeu là
redon
pis
c'est le futur que vous avez créé vous
venez de signer l'arrêt de mort du monde
entier